hello everyone and yes we finally get to
see a game from the match dingler and
versus wei yi this is the sixth the game
of their match the first the five games
were a fairly short draw so we decided
to skip those uh but this one may or may
not be a draw uh so let's dive straight
into it and see
how ding played his 22nd game of the
required 30 games that are required for
him to qualify to defeat a candidate's
tournament so here ning has the white
pieces and he opens with d4 we have
knight to f6 uh we have c uh c4 e6 g3
going for the catalan opening and now d5
striking in the center we have bishop to
g to end the bishop to e7 uh knight to
f3 bing is now ready to castle and the
both players now castle so castles caps
castles and the d captures on c4 uh this
is basically a classical line of the
catalan uh so queen to c2 ding is now
ready to reclaim his his pawn we have a6
preparing b5 and before grabbing the
pawn thing stops b5 so he plays a4
bishop to d7 now uh getting ready to
counter a white slide square bishop here
by playing bishop to c6 so queen
captures in c4 and bishop the c6 now
this has all been played before nothing
new happening here bishop to g5 and now
knight b to d7 uh we have rook to d1 and
now a5 uh and here uh queen to c1 is a
known move in the position but after
knight b to d2 biting it is now already
acid move 12 that we have a completely
new game
so h6 asking what do you do with the
bishop here you can't really go to h4
and going
backwards doesn't really
look like it's doing anything you could
play bishop f4 bishop to e3 uh but dean
knows what he's doing so he captures an
f6 with knight captures and now rook a
to c1 putting more pressure on this c7
pawn so the bishop here cannot move
white is preparing knight to the e5 so
the bishops will get traded off and then
ding will have some very nice pressure
along the c file so here we have queen
to e8 now getting ready to
defend here but also just attacking that
a four pawn twice so ding first has to
defend this and only now rook to c8 so
now the bishop can move and the c7 pawn
will be defended knights to e5 offering
a trait of light square bishops also
grabbing that beautiful e5 square for
his knight bishop caltras and g2 king
captures and now of course we want to
advance our pawn to c5 and the way he is
doing perfectly fine here uh nothing uh
wrong with his position whatsoever uh so
knight d to f3 improving the position of
that knight on d2 and bishop to d6 now
now with h4 by dean grabbing more space
on the king's side c captures on d for
opening up an attack to the queen queen
captures and now rook captures on c1
going for some traits here rook captures
on c1 and queen to b8 now uh putting
pressure on the and that e5 knight uh
also defending the bishop and also
making room for this rook to
enter the game so rook to c4 and uh rook
to d8 now and it seems like you are
threatening some discoveries here but uh
you know fair in fairness there aren't
any impressive discoveries like but
sorry about that bishop to b4 could be
one of the nicer ones maybe getting a
nice outpost for the bishop and getting
uh grabbing hold of the open d file for
your rook but other than that nothing
really serious so being just plays e4
could be very useful the knight and
bishop are
on well maybe unpleasant square so if e5
can be played that should be should be
great uh and then now comes knight the
e8 uh like we said bishop to b4 is a
fine discovery but
it's not all that much let's say queen
b2 we're going to play rook to c8 we
could trade off a pair of rooks and uh
that should be good for uh for
uh way however uh here he tries knight
the e8 and now ding grabs more space on
the king side we have h5 and now uh he
goes back knights to f6 he goes after
the h5 pawn and this is where his uh uh
troubles begin here ding plays queen b6
he says all right you can have your h5
phone i'm going to grab the a5 pawn so
this is what he does tonight captures an
h5 queen captures an a5 but now the
problem is uh if ding moves his knight
from the center of the board let's say
knight captures an f7 uh then we can
pick up this knight on h5 for free so
here we brings it back but now feel free
to pause the video and try to find the
absolute strongest move for ding
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this idea
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is again knight
captures on f7 because now uh yes there
is no knight on h5 that we can pick up
but the knight and bishop are perfectly
aligned for this e5 push so king
captures an f7 and now comes e5
attacking the bishop and the knight and
knight to d5 now we're going to capture
on d6 queen captures on d6 and now queen
back to e1 and if you look at the
position now the material is completely
even uh but ding's king is much much
safer a ways king is already on f7 and
it could be
uh difficult defending it so here he
goes back into g8 now comes queen to e4
we have uh rook to e8 uh helping out
with the defense of the pawn as this is
an isolated pawn we're gonna be able to
attack it very easily so b4 now a5 b5 a6
could create a pass pawn at some point
knight to b6 attacking things rook ended
the pawn on a4 and now rook to d4
attacking the queen we have knights to
d5 blocking again
hoping to get some sort of a draw by
repetition but just knight to e5 and
here you can see how easily ding is
winning some very very crucial squares
we have rook to f8 and now comes point
a5 we have broke the f5 putting pressure
on the knight here but now knight to d3
and here we have queen to e7 and knight
to c5 now putting again pressure on that
e6 pawn so king to f7 defending it now
comes rook to d2
uh and uh here we have b6 attacking the
a5 pawn but also the knight here and
interestingly here ding is completely
winning and he plays a move that uh uh
gives uh
well maybe gives a wii a bit too much
space to recover his position uh here
after b6 rook captures on d5 is just a
game over but it's not easy to spot of
course you can't capture with the pawn
because the rook hangs but if you
capture with the rook now we play eight
captures on b6 and yes black is up the
exchange but we have a pass pawn here
and turns out this past pawn is
unstoppable let's say rook d8 we're
gonna play queen f4 check king to g8
we're gonna play b7 uh you're never
getting rid of this pawn because you're
never getting rid of this knight from c5
so queen eight we have to guard the
queening square
but now queen to c7 and after something
like king to h7 we're going to play b5
it's a critical move uh uh guards the c6
square which will be important to
prevent any checks and now after any
move because we are just threatening to
pick up the pawn and then we'll grab the
rook here uh even if e5 just knight e6
and that's uh it we're threatening
checkmate we're threatening to pick up
the rook so once checkmate is uh stopped
we're gonna win the rook then we're
gonna promote our b pawn to a queen and
that's it so uh very interesting that
ding did not go for this rook captures
on the e5 but he probably saw that the
other plan was also
very nice so he played knight to d3 uh
and now we have queen to b7 uh because
here b captures on a5 is the only real
way to go uh somehow trying to stop that
past pawn but even this would be very
hard to hold so instead after knight to
the three queen to b7 was played uh and
now what do you do uh here okay knight
to f4 check could be tricky then you
might lose the queen but ding of course
plays rook to a2 now the queen is nicely
defended and also you are threatening
queen captures on e6 so rook to f6
defending that and now a captures on b6
and here uh queen to a8 was played but
it was also in this position on mu 41
that wei yi resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here uh
instead of this queen a8 move you might
think okay let's just capture the pawn
and see what happens the problem is 95
check and after the king moves we can
play queen h7 and everything is just
falling apart the knight on e5 is too
strong a piece and there's no way for
uh for for black to survive this uh
there's no way to defend the pawn it's
just a very ugly position if you try
something like this then even this
monster fork is possible knight to d7
check uh forking absolutely everything
um
uh so
that that would not be a good idea uh so
yeah after this uh the queen retreat to
the eighth square we resign the game and
uh being lyran wins the game six and uh
that also means that he wins the match
there will be no tie breaks no
armageddon uh and that means that he has
fulfilled uh 22 games now of the
required 30 and he still needs eight
more classical games uh in order to have
enough classical games to
be considered as a participant for the
for the next few day candidates
tournament so i will keep you informed
uh
uh we'll see what ding does next and we
are gonna cover uh well his uh
presumable success and uh well we will
just take it from there uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
thank you for uh always suggesting the
absolute best stuff uh i would like to
wish a very happy birthday to hunter uh
laurie loddy look who's 40 and happy
birthday jgg yes to dumplings uh and i
would also like to thank zoran through
stitch bitcoin lightning please and
nagarjuna ponogoti for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing to check up on ding's
progress and uh whatever you guys uh
suggest in the comments and on the email
and on you know social networks and of
course everything else that happens in
the chess world so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your sunday